I always love spending some time with
Doug Williams the Redskins senior vice
president player development first round
pick by the Tampa Bay Buccaneers back in
1978 got a biopic based on his life
coming out Doug joins us on the program
wow that's quite a tiger you have behind
us your Grambling tiger behind us Doug
that's menacing oh do you have your Mook
your mute button on your on a silent
count at the line of scrimmage there and
you weren't saying take me back I know
that you have a book an autobiography
called quarter black why do you respond
or why did you title it quarter black
well you know because everywhere I went
when I came out Danny you can remember
going to Tampa every article that was
written it was never Doug wins the
quarterback of the Buccaneers is it was
either Tampa Bay black quarterback I
either Doug Williams Tampa Bay's black
quarterback and and if you read early in
the book I always say baby one who tied
it a quarter black so that was a good
name for the book and I remember didn't
somebody ask you how long you been a
black quarterback when you were at the
Super Bowl that was the one media day I
mean Butch Jones bless his soul he's
gone on to heaven now I knew butch
because he worked in Jackson Mississippi
with the table but and I looked at that
from a standpoint you got a guy he was
nervous he wanted to get his questions
out because so many people was around I
don't think he meant it the way it came
out and he just want to know how long
I've been black my answer to him was
since I left brandman because when I was
at Grambling I wasn't black I wonder if
the Buccaneers didn't draft you in the
first round I wonder if you would have
been drafted in the first round do you
think you still would have been taken in
the first round I do I really do
the two teams I think that was a great
possibility and let me say it before I
get there June Jones I think we all know
who June Jones yeah
Jew Jones was the backup quarterback for
the Atlanta Falcons a behind Steve
Bukowski and we played the Atlanta
Falcons tempering that the faculty a DIN
after the game June Jones walked up to
me said man it's a shame he said cuz
actually you should have been the number
one pick in the whole draft and you know
that's that's to hear that but I think
Tampa was smart enough to know that
black quarterback coming out in 1978
they could trade and get some most draft
picks and everything and I probably
still read it at number 17 and they made
that move so that's what happened but I
do bleed two other teams and and and
just just from from conversation with
these team during that time and that was
either the Dallas Cowboy give brand and
and and and John talked to them alive at
that particular time in the other was
Bart Starr at Green Bay oh that would
have been interesting agreed they had
two draft picks that year they pick Jane
lost it and I don't know who they picked
down the thing that was picking 26 early
on and then number 26 so I could have
even been the late pick for the Green
Bay Packers how did you keep this inside
what you you know you were experiencing
racism at the time but I don't know to
what degree well for me to be able to
handle it and even to today Dan you know
I think I handled it with Hannah with a
lot of grace because I grew up in south
Louisiana and I understood what racism
was way back when you know born in 1955
so I was in a young boy doing the civil
rights time so you can you sit around
you hear you grandmother and your
granddaddy your mom your dad talk about
what's going on you know I knew every
Friday night from crossroad across for a
rally of there was a crossing crossroad
down to my right was about a mile and
down on my left was about a mile and in
between there it was all black families
so every Friday night
that was a cross burning at those those
intersection and you know all the man's
in the neighborhood when the crawls go
up we're getting at cars and trucks you
know with their guns and stuff to try to
find out who was brand across you know
it's one of those scare tactics back in
the day as to stay in your place and I
can remember going on the way to Baton
Rouge this small town actually
Zakhar I'm exactly small-town Baker I
remember stopping at the red light one
time little boy in the back of the
collar my dad and actually guy with a
hood came up to give us a template of
the Ku Klux Klan I mean that's how
friendly he was back in the day so you
understood what she was up against back
in those days
wait a member of the KKK gave you a
pamphlet your dad a pamphlet my dad
didn't take it I mean he walked to the
car at the red light it was kind of like
when you you go place and you see people
who are kind of a homeless action for
money yeah it was walking around passing
out families and everybody who stopped
at the red light
I guess recruiting for the Ku Klux Klan
how'd your dad explain why they're
burning across and why these these men
are wearing sheets over their heads
well the most important thing for us was
you know five boys three girls was
always being the right place at the
right time don't get caught in
situations that something cruel can
happen to you you know my dad I'm always
talked about some of the things that
happen you know you talk about people
getting you know murdered and stuff like
that nobody ever find out what happened
to him you know things like that he just
it was almost a scare tactic back in the
day as don't do this and then I
remembered when LSU and Ole Miss played
you know the highway that I live off was
like a main strip from Mississippi all
the way to Baton Rouge because I lived
off plank road highway 67 and when they
played each other when when Ole Miss had
to come to Baton Rouge we was not
allowed to be on the streets at that
particular time because crazy stuff
happened people throw stuff out the
window and I did one day going from my
house to my grandmother house who lived
about
half a mile down and walking on the
Nutri Brown got hit in the face with a
chocolate malt
you know just though haven't had to be
chocolate so it tastes pretty good
he's Doug Williams the Redskins senior
vice president of player development
former Super Bowl MVP you know I thought
of Super Bowl 22 Timmy Smith your
running back he was number 20 was he
what was his number 36 36 Tony Lilly was
22 what knee Tony Lilly was the
defensive back of the Broncos I felt bad
you were picking on Tony Lilly in Super
Bowl 20 you were picking on 22 in Super
Bowl 22 Doug Tony Tony got burned
I remember the Ricky Grant TV on the
play axle and on a 60 count of
play-action you know we ran the 60 count
of so well all the time and he came up
and bid on the run and it was almost
like it was almost like when rent went
there Ricky went behind I could see him
turn around and saying I think he's a
high school coach now in this area high
school coach in the Virginia area I saw
him about about three years ago if you
should do show up in your Redskins
jersey and with a football there and see
his reaction there now you know it was
more overt you were mentioning the
racism that you face but then you get
into the NFL where it's a little more
covert it feels like what was that like
the difference of growing up and then
you go to the NFL where you think I'm a
first-round draft pick I'm successful we
are almost going to the Super Bowl with
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers the worst team
in football two years earlier and then
what happens well you know think about
it
Oakley's say you can't go a little
further south didn't than Florida
Florida and you know when I first got
there my first year was good but at the
same time you know we
five and seven my my five and eleven my
roof yeah I got my job broke and all
that and Ricki bail bless his soul yeah
consoled me probably every week when
things weren't going well and people was
born Ricki Bell was the one to put his
arms around me and say hey I've had to
go through it man it's tough but just
just keep going forward and the second
year was was great Dan you know cuz we
was winning we wanted the first five
games out the box and had we lost three
in a row down the stretch and had to win
the last game of the year and other
getting the playoffs and we did that
three nothing against the Kansas City
chief and it was almost a total cliche
from worst to first so that was great
but the next couple of years you know
the fans was a little different I can
remember her walking to the sideline and
that was a lady understand I see it not
with some replays lay this thin head
look like darling like this on a rope
just David I guess they let's hang him
you know oh no fan mail
you know you get fan mail with knoweth
no I'll return address you open it up
you just throw the trash King but the
one that really got me was I had an
icebox I mean I you know it's amazing
how much time it took the wrap this box
and when I open that box
it was a round watermelon in there and a
note let's say throw it to the easy end
they can catch this I mean that was
truly amazing to think that much time to
put a Robert rotten watermelon in there
to write a a rotten note but you almost
taken this team to the Super Bowl and
then these fans turned on you then
quickly well then you know we all got to
be real 1978 it went so much about turn
always the idea you got a black
quarterback you got a black quarterback
you know it was almost unheard of it
wasn't used to no matter what you did it
wasn't good enough that's just the way
it was not understood there you know
coach Rob used to always tell her hell
you just got to go out and not play on
you know and and then they could do
pilot you can play a gram you could play
anywhere and that's the attitude we took
and I have my older brother to come
flying in and and James Harris who are
called all the time
but the good thing I had John McKay I
had John McKay here's a guy that in 1965
and in the middle of civil rights
movement Jimmy John's was his
quarterback yeah I think it lets you
know it wasn't about color with John
McKay with his quarterback and he felt
like he always told me he said Doug
ain't no doubt about it he say you know
the best athlete gonna play for me and
the best player he say so you don't have
to worry about him and you know always
what's funny what Coach McKay's there
and he was so III don't say ahead of his
time I mean he he was but everybody
should have been ahead of their time or
it should have been what was real in the
moment but here's a guy who you guys he
takes a USC team to Alabama and all of a
sudden Bear Bryant sees these great
athletes there and all of a sudden says
I gotta get me some of those great
athletes there and it was okay he was
passionate about his players and even
care what color they were at one point
before I got there I could remember they
told me that he was going up in the
stand at a fan for for somebody to
yelling my take the man's back to the
California you know because he had a
bunch of guys from California off the
USC team and rightfully so it was with
it so you you all guys who to win but
coach McKay protected is clear no matter
what color they were one there a time
when you were starting in the NFL I
don't know if this was Tampa maybe it
was Washington but you were the at least
50th highest-paid quarterback in the NFL
at the time does that sound about right
I was in Tampa I was number 54 and you
were starting I was a 54 who's only 2018
if I do the math they're the backup
quarterback
Mike Ray who had played at SC my crane
was making buddies my back no how do you
not get angry or did you that well you
know what that's a good question not
that I did get angry but you know what
what could I've done back then you and I
both know back then
you got cut and somebody going telephone
them and tell you you know I wouldn't
take this guy you know he's this and
he's dead he was gone
what no salary cap replication what
nothing you know you just like to leave
so to me it was all about being humble
and being winning for what you have to
deal with you know I played played all
my life for nothing in college in high
school and enjoy the game with my as a
business but at the same time he was
getting paid and mind I've been fairly
but after the five year was up when it
was time to negotiate I respected then I
just brought up a couple of minutes ago
prior to you joining us that I think
Kaepernick and the best landing spot
would be Kansas City and Erie just won a
Super Bowl he brought in Michael Vick
after he went to prison you got the most
secure position in football with Patrick
mahomes and you could bring him in as a
backup quarterback just to get him back
in the game and then maybe he gets a
fair shot with somebody after that a
real contract a real offer what do you
think about that you talking about a
number one individual you know I had an
opportunity to talk to Anna Reed right
after he brought Mike a big bag and and
what I asked him was coach give me one
reason why you you brain like a big big
bag and he told me he was as real as
real can get you know he had two sons
and and they had gotten in a little
trouble he say hey my son got in trouble
he said everybody deserves a second
chance and then you know what that was
good enough for me and I think if
anybody could could was dumb at that and
Hannah are Kapernick and and and and
meant to him and understand where he's
coming from it would be in theory if you
didn't go to the USFL then you go to
Oklahoma I believe I wonder like how
important that was for you to get back
into the NFL to be honest with Danny
wasn't okay I didn't that play one
single down a football in 1983 and
always looked at it from
at that point you know when I went to
grab and state university was not to
play professional football I went there
to get a degree and help them finish
their education to be a coach my oldest
brother was my first coach I wanted to
be like my oldest brother and in 1983
when went through the contract situation
with the Buccaneers I spent the whole
year had logged Western middle school in
Zachary where my brother was the
principal as a substitute teacher and so
and you know and then I had a you know
baby girl at that particular time so
football wasn't that important to me in
1983 because I just lost my wife and in
83 was you realize in life that football
might not be as important as life and
the most important thing is you being
happy doing what you wanted to who's
gonna play you in the movie that's a
good course I don't know you know my
kids and I was on a zoomcar with him
last night and all they was talking
about in there the tailor made suits
ready and they black dress I got a son
who's actually the quantity control
coach in the quarterback room down in
New Orleans and he said with dad I could
clear Youngberg windows all right
can he throw like you I tell you what
had a good arm he's tall and skinny
though he's about six four he played for
me at grandma and we did win a
conference championship with him so but
he's been down there was Sean Payton the
last three years so he's doing pretty
good did the Redskins consider Colin
Kaepernick since you work with them has
that conversation as ever as that ever
come they never come up then I think
what happened here you know we were in a
heavily heavily
military air and I think the guy that
sits and on Pennsylvania Avenue 69
Pennsylvania Avenue has made such a big
stink of the fans in this area might
have been a tough situation for for both
the team and in him and sometime you
don't want to bring people in and in a
situation where nobody's gonna be happy
and I think that's that's probably
I didn't come up doing that time great
to talk to you as always I wish you luck
with the movie hope you find somebody
handsome who can throw a nice spiral to
play you in the movie and the book is
quarterblack
it's Doug Williams the former Super Bowl
hero great to talk to you again Doug
thanks they appreciate it